When you look at a picture
with a certain degree of ambiguity,
your perception heightens it,
and you try to figure it out
from all kinds of possible references.
You don't know what it is,
and you are completely open
to any kind of way
of thinking about it.
When I knew that
The Museum of Modern Art
was organizing
Stieglitz at Lake George,
I went to see it in an afternoon.
That show got me in a mood
of looking for things in things,
which is something that you do
when you look at clouds
one way or another.
And the beautiful thing
about Stieglitz's Equivalents
is the fact that you're
always seeing forms in clouds,
in the Equivalents you don't.
You just see clouds.
I just saw the show,
and right after leaving it
you had these amazing marble floors.
I kept thinking about clouds,
and when I left,
I looked at the floor,
and I saw all these clouds,
and then I took the camera
and I started shooting the clouds
right there, and this whole thing...
I remember, I used to work there.
I was there,
I remember those floors well.
And then what I did,
I went to the gift shop,
and I got a piece of paper to draw
and a little pair of scissors,
and I made these little round things
that looked like the moon,
and I started shooting it there.
And a security guy came
and tried to ask me what I was doing,
and I said, “No, I'm just
taking pictures of the floor.”
And then he was like,
“Ah, you cannot do this.”
I said, “Why not, I'm just
taking pictures of the floor.
I mean, people take pictures
of the artworks and you don't mind.”
And I went out to the street,
I came back,
and I shot like four rolls of film.
I wanted to make something
that looked just like a Stieglitz
but then it was just the floor
of the museum
in front of the exhibition
where a Stieglitz was.
When you're dealing with something
that seems familiar to you,
it's great because first of all
you're open to it,
and you look at it as something
that you want to see again.
But then there's this double-take.
You realize that that is not
what you thought it was.
That feeling is quite effective
in creating a lasting impression
and starting a conversation.
And before you know it,
you're implicated in a series
of questions about
what's in front of you.
You're not just looking at something,
you're actually thinking
about the way
you're looking at something.
This is the kind of interaction
that I want my works
to have with the viewer.
When you think of photographs
as processes, not as products,
you start really understanding
what they really mean.
My mother came to one of my shows,
and the first time
she stepped into a museum
was to see one of my exhibitions,
so I make work for her.
If she won't like it,
I don't think it's good.
Maybe I am one of these artists
that don't take any pride
for not being understood
and being ahead of my time.
I'm right here right now,
and I want people to get it
or to feel at least something
because I make work in a way,
I don't make it
for any specific public,
and it has something for everybody.